This is identification this is Station seven with faith bender
and the tape of it in a few seconds invited occasion this is site to. FACE. You have an amazing photograph.
Just behind us which has as a group a group of men taken at the Berlin festival
and they include a frank hearty pep lonely reader and Shostakovich and could you talk about that photograph
and about the people who were at the festival. Well.
We got together a group of us got together in different school buildings
or whatever was standing in what it was left standing. And.
One of the young German people who were looking after us said Would you like to go
and meet some of the of the delegates not mentioning that. There.
They've got some cheese there and that was important and they all have some wine I think are said oh yes I'd like to.
So we went off and this was how I remember.
The building or three well but I remember the room and there was nothing in the room. Nothing whatsoever.
And the cheese and the prayer and it was just on the floor.
And there was a man sitting there who beckoned me to sit next to him next to him and he picked up my.
And he said You've got beautiful. I have to confess I.
Nothing obvious because you know that women everywhere didn't worry me until I suppose thirty years later
when Russell Drysdale said to me I want to paint your hands and then I remember for shots and he held my hand
and I looked at his hand and it was almost as black as mine with nicotine.
And he had a fair bit of cheese and red wine by this time and he was you know jolly. And there was an alder.
Gramophone in the corner you know that you wind up.
And someone had put one of his compositions on and a young man and he was just and exact.
Playing this record these records a little pile of them and they were seventy eight.
So of course they had to be changed every three and a half minutes or so. And it was and he was this company.
Beating time with the other end. And I recall reading poetry. I didn't know this poetry at all.
You know I was pretty sure that you know you. Music but your best bet was. I can't remember who took the photographs.
I have a feeling it was a member of it and screw the would have limited events at that party
but I can tell you we went to Charlie and who got stuck into the wall and the T. Hese really. Surrounded the whole has.
Limits. Well. At the end of oh I must not forget to tell you that when I arrived in valley.
Who should I meet another man whom I had met at an International Peace Congress and. I stayed with him and his wife.
One hundred forty or fifty not quite sure. Just before he went to Philly and they were there.
And he was on she was on sabbatical. She was the first woman engineer in Australia.
And he was the chief of the Forestry Department Tory had just under four hours from
and this was in the Cold War was beginning and they were out to trap him. Because he was a left wing.
And he would have framed him. So he resigned.
And picked up best picked up the money and went off and explained quite some years
and months in India before going on to believe. And their relationship wasn't the best.
They were only speaking to each other. So they named. ALAN KOHLER Of course his name.
He was involved in a very serious accident Victoria. And lost a leg. And he was travelling quite.
Driving managing quite well. Minus one leg. I think that happened around in the big push for. Anyhow. So there he was.
And he was one came back to see this person whom I had a conference and he said to me where I was staying
and I told him so we got together and he said to me I then said Look I've got a friend here
and I think you should meet him. And I took him to meet.
And they were very impressed with each other they were good company.
And said look the East German forestry looking for very experienced engineers. I think you should apply.
I think they did. And they were also having trouble with.
Housing they pigs and the pigs would have wanted this because they'd killed all the good brains of any. Perhaps.
The housing of Pigs which was extremely important to the country. Main source of. Meat. So.
Couple of years here would be interesting and he was speaking a fair bit. So he went to the Forestry Department.
I think she took him. And talked staying in Germany and they were enthusiastic court yesterday. I didn't look that.
I remember him telling me like. He didn't like the look of one.
And he said to me at the time I think it was the top Nazi. The day after he was arrested and police.
Taken to the police station all or none of us knew. And was told he forces and he would have to pay the price.
And I kept in the here for about six hours. Fortunately he was going to meet with us to learn most of it.
So it was found out what had happened.
You know I mean the irony here of communism was quite prevalent there in East Berlin. They had us all on their control.
And they known to us you know all that was of it was he released. He was released he was released.
And he and his wife in life.
So that made me feel very uncomfortable exceptionally uncomfort uncomfortable and the thing that.
That disturbed me most of all. The Communists in the delegation.
Could see no wrong in anything that was done by our hosts nothing.
I just want to come back to a slow who said to me one morning. She came and picked me up but.
You know they we only had in the schools we only had a bed. So that was it. There was no way to put it.
And I cannot tell you have a primitive the washing facilities were but it didn't matter.
Anyhow and she came and picked me up and she said.
I want to take you to make my brother he was a Nazi and I didn't like him but I'd still like to meet him
and he was lecturing in the university. So she did the edge and. When we left she said. He gave his life to.
Yes So there were very.
Can I just ask you something about just because of age talk politics because of course he was at that stage I would
have thought quite well known as an opponent of the Russian government.
Not quite at that time because I would never have let him into his trial.
But it happened after that and I think actually it happened around about the mid sixty's if I can remember.
And he wasn't going to talk politics he just wanted to have a bloody good time. Anyhow.
The leaders of delegation quarter sort. And said now.
The delegations from the other countries have invited to visit a country and I read up at least the. So many to Moscow.
So many going to many to China. And it went on. And maybe I was going with a group.
That was to go to Gary or of all places. Well of course Belgariad and the communists in it but it was in many ways.
So let me come back so that they said you have to pack today and you're going off tomorrow.
And I think there were about five of us from the delegation that went on to about Kerry.
And the trains once again took us off at a very slow pace. And I was pleased because I was able to see.
Czechoslovakia which was green again. And we stopped in the station and proud.
Came and greeted me and she put her arms around me. And the tears came. We have suffered.
Lost so many of our own people and war is a terrible thing when you go back to Australia.
Make sure that I work for peace. I admired the white jumper she had at our.
And she took it all pulled it off and gave it to me. It was beautiful.
We didn't stay as long as I would like to have stayed going through.
But the ducks if we were here you know they'd succeeded in getting their backs off the ground again.
But she'd come to the station just wanting to greet one particular person. And. She brought a little. Little pottery.
And put it in my hands and then the train moved off and we went on to Poland.
And we also we had in the train the delegates who were going to go on to the Soviet Union
and I think we're going to I'm not sure where they were changing. Trains it could have been in Warsaw.
But when we got off. And we were retained there and taken to the Margaret Margaret. For a night out by the locals.
And the man who was sort of leader of the group. Was a pianist. Anyhow they took us in about it.
And he said this is the this is where the British Bush was he played
and in fact it was a place where what was the name of that awful King. It would've Yes The Nazi. That's right.
Well Simpson and.
KING Did all the playing apparently on this particular are not well we played at the end staff eight of them.
I just want to say when I went back to that was simple depressed
when I went back to put a pistol space about fifteen years after the war they didn't think most of the bullets were
still on the wall. So sad terrible but anyhow. We went up from the to Bucharest. And once again. Had a wonderful time.
Took us out to their nightclubs I think we stayed about two nights there because the trains move so slowly so you had
to give other trains a go. To two artists delegation were given scholarships but they remain in people to paint.
One is very famous in Australia. I think of his name later. I can think of his name. So. We went on from there.
And finally. I should really have have the photograph a to show you of all in Sofia in vogue area and.
I came off this train and just looked at a sea of faces. And the who cannot describe it.
I couldn't see anything but just faces.
It looked as though the whole city had closed up to the railway station and taken to the best hotel in the city.
And I wasn't used to. Any have taken to the hill and there I was being waited on.
You know the servants couldn't do a half and what. And she made my bed.
Took my laundry who I am I couldn't believe this. And she became rather friendly. One morning she could. I mean.
With the whole record. And among the records were records of Paul.
But the racist and the means to being about twelve were preachers of STAR loans.
Oh yes you see the Bulgarian working class and the vast majority were peasants and workers. Well into the country.
It was being controlled. Nobody could question.
It was blatant but then so it was great because they had food to eat
and they worked for wages many of whom never worked. So we arrived there and were made very welcome.
As I said then couple of their leaders came in and said We are taking you to a welcome.
Local Council I think it was all the equivalent.
And the prime minister will be there so we went along
and we danced with the prime minister in the horror you know real not club that was one day I got a lot of photographs
and there I am with two The members of the dance group and they are also all of these blokes
and these people got so drunk on slivovitz so much so we thought God where is the hotel.
Not to be where he picked us up took us. This is amazing response to you. Was it.
Patti that you were a novelty or had been advanced publicist.
There was nothing other than my performance in early June. Nothing. And not only that you see.
I work I guess our voice unique. I think they want us.
I said that they expected the whole delegation to be polite and to hear the word true because one. Do you understand.
It's quite a personal if and.